- When the waiter comes back,
just ask him to slip his
number on the napkin.
- Um, any chance you could
just write your number
down on like, a receipt
or a napkin or something?
- [Waiter] Yeah, could we
leave it at a "we'll see?"
(rusty hinge squeak)
(jazz trumpet music)
- We did a video together
where we were handcuffed
to each other for 24 hours.
It wasn't as terrible as I expected.
- You might not have
thought it was as bad,
my hand, when I got burned--
(fire alarm siren)
- Yeah you did get burned
while we were trying to cook.
The girl I picked for
Will to go on a date with,
I'm very proud of myself.
I feel like Cupid here because I think
that this is going to be
a match made in heaven.
The twist here is that we're
going to have an ear piece
telling each other exactly
what to say and what to do.
I feel like I'm gonna be
so tempted to just like,
completely sabotage the whole thing
just for my own personal entertainment.
(laughs)
Pinky promise me right now you're gonna do
exactly what I tell you to do
and say what I'm gonna tell you to say.
- I will do exactly what you tell me to do
and I will say exactly
what you tell me to say.
- Okay.
- [Juliana] Nice to meet you!
- [Will] Nice to meet you too.
- I have so much power
in my hands right now.
- So where do you live?
- I live in the Valley.
But I'm originally from Texas.
- I'm from Charlotte, North Carolina.
- Is it cold there?
- It does get cold.
If it snows two inches,
the town shuts down.
- Tell her that you're from the South
so you're kind of afraid of the snow.
- I'm from the South, so I'm
a little bit afraid of snow,
cause people from the
South can't really drive.
- They can't drive in it at all.
- No.
The second it snows,
like, people freak out.
- What'd you move here for?
- I moved here because I had a new job
and I wanted to put
myself in an environment
that would make me grow.
- Ask her why she moved to L.A..
- Why did you move here?
- I do stand-up comedy.
- What's, like, your style of--
- Lately it's been like,
literally like, dad jokes.
- Ask her for her best dad joke.
- Tell me your best dad joke.
- Oh my gosh.
(laughs)
Nobody's gonna laugh.
Okay.
(clears throat)
Saw a cute homeless guy the other day.
Guess you could call
me a homeless romantic.
(laughing)
- Now tell her you want
to tell her a dad joke.
- I'm gonna tell you a dad joke.
- Say, what did the father chimney--
- Say to the son chimney?
- I know this one.
But I don't remember it.
Go.
Go go go.
Say it.
- No, ask her what the punch line is.
- What do you think
like, the punch line is?
- Wait, say it again?
- Just tell her, you're
too young to smoke!
- You're too young to smoke!
- Oh okay, I get it.
- It's the worst joke ever, I know.
- It's a dad joke, cause it's about a dad.
- Ask her what she was like growing up.
- So what were you like
when you were growing up?
- What I am today, just like
(makes staccato energetic noises)
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Kind of a lot.
- Yeah, like a lot.
- Will, you just called her a lot!
Take back that statement.
- I didn't mean to like offend
you by saying you're a lot.
- No it didn't.
I love it.
That's like a compliment.
- Say how much you love her personality.
- I'm a lot too, so I mean-
- Good.
- We could be a lot together.
- Well it's better than being boring.
- Oh wait, waiter's back.
- Yeah, we'll take a quick look.
- The waiter's hot.
Set me up with the waiter.
(laughs)
- Okay, so I'm gonna have the Kale Caesar.
- No tomatoes.
- Say the reason why is
because I recently listened
to a podcast with a evolutionary biologist
and he said tomatoes are
indigenously poisonous
to humans.
Most people don't know.
- So I actually don't
want tomatoes in my meal
because I listened to a podcast recently,
that says that um, tomatoes
are indigenously contagious-
- Poisonous.
Not contagious.
- Poisonous!
To humans.
- Peanuts too!
- You sound so L.A..
- No tomatoes for me.
- Everybody in L.A. is
like, this is bad for you,
don't eat it, it's gonna kill you.
That's you.
- I mean, what else can I say?
- I'm out.
No I'm just kidding.
(laughs)
- Ah, look at this.
- [Waiter] Here ya are.
Almost had those mixed up.
- Oh perfect, thank you.
- She wants tomatoes.
- Oh, looks good!
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- So you got bread and tomatoes.
- I didn't know it came with bread.
Am I breaking some L.A. rule?
- Yeah, you're so not L.A..
- What is it called again?
- That's um--
- It's what you put on
your eyes, with, uh...
- Yeah, that's a cucumber.
- Cucumber!
Do you like cucumbers?
- I do like--
- They're feeding each other!
- That's good.
- Things escalated quickly here.
Ask her what she likes to do...
- In your free time.
- I like going to Mulholland Drive.
- Where's that?
- It's in between Studio
City and Hollywood.
- Oh, okay.
- Jim Carrey is the one
who inspired me to do
stand-up comedy.
But he used to go to the
top of Mulholland Drive
and write himself, like a--
- He would go to the top of the mountain--
- And he'd write himself a check.
Yeah.
- Ask her if she believes
in the law of attraction,
but say it with a seductive
twinkle in your eye.
- Do you believe in the law of attraction?
- How you manifest what you desire?
- Yeah, like how you
manifest what you desire?
- Oh, yeah.
Okay, this is coming back.
You know, you're so funny.
Everybody in L.A. is about the universe!
- Yeah.
- There's nothing wrong
with that.
- [Waiter] I don't mean to
interrupt, is everything
tasting alright?
- Oh yeah, it's great.
- [Will] This is amazing.
- Wait, Will!
Ask the waiter for his number.
- Uh, excuse me sir, actually-
- Tell him you're asking for a friend.
- Is there any chance I
could get your phone number?
- You're asking for a friend.
- I don't personally want it, but...
- [Waiter] Gotcha.
Um...
- He hasn't even asked for my number.
You're lucky.
- Sounds like it's going well.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
Alright.
- Tell her sorry about that
I was asking for a friend.
- You're just hilarious, honestly you are.
- You're funny too.
Thank you.
- I'm funny?
- He's doing great.
Ask her what she looks for in a partner.
- Ooh, that's easy.
Someone who's funny.
- So, X on that.
- No, I mean, you're...
(laughs)
- Someone who eats
dressing on their salad.
Just kidding.
(laughs)
He's pissed about the salad.
Muahahaha!
Ask her how she thinks the date's going--
- So far?
- It's like a lot of fun.
I haven't been on a date in a while.
- So it's a lot of fun because
you haven't been on a date
in a while, or it's actually a lot of fun?
- In general, it's a great date.
- Okay.
- It's a great date!
Look at me.
- I haven't been on a
date in a while either.
- Really?
- I'm taking all the credit for this.
- Ask her if she'd like
to go on a second date.
- I know I haven't been super
hilarious this whole date.
and this has been like,
okay, and the wine--
- He's discrediting his humor,
which is discrediting my humor.
- Would you wanna go on a second date?
- Heck yeah!
- Yeah?
- Where?
Um, I'm not gonna tell you.
- Ooh!
I love surprises!
- Yeah.
- You totally t-ed me up
and you gave me all the ammo
that I needed, and that's
why next time I go on a date
I'm gonna put you in my ear again.
- Okay, that will be 500 dollars please.
This was fun, and I can walk away knowing
that in karmic law, this
will come back around to me.
(jazz music)
- [Sky] So we'll set up
a second date for you,
and 100 dollars an hour.
Cheers to that.